le chef de l'État n'en a parlé dans les
journaux il est ce matin à Rungis au
contact des Français dit-il qui se
lèvent tôt on voit un petit peu le
l'accent Nicolas Sarkozy avait déjà
parlé de cette expression qui est venu
parler du travail et des retraites mais
aussi pouvoir d'achat il y a quelques
années quand on promettait le plein
emploi ou quand on promettait finalement
d'inverser la cour du chômage personne
n'y croyait et nous ne sommes pas
revenus c'est cette France qui travaille
qui aujourd'hui supporte l'essentiel par
exemple du poids fiscal en France qui
est exclu des cadeaux fiscaux de
Monsieur Macron et donc pour le moment
c'est plus un exercice de comme ou
d'après vente on sait tous que vivant
plus âgés
enfin le miracle on veut préserver un
système par répartition il faut qu'on
travaille plus longtemps donc ça je dis
pas ça me fait plaisir ça fait plaisir à
personne quand il faut travailler un peu
plus longtemps et ça n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle près d'un Français sur deux est
aujourd'hui en situation de surpoids
selon une récente étude et surtout on y
apprend que le taux d'obésité a doublé
en France sont près de 30 ans
on est obligé de France
on est obligé 10000 euros
les chiffres datant de 2020 montre une
hausse de l'obésité surtout chez les
jeunes Français les 18-34 ans une
augmentation qui s'explique avant tout
par l'alimentation plus que par le
manque d'exercice manuel Macron qui
profite de cet échange pour interpeller
la députée insoumise du Val-de-Marne
Rachel kéké qui l'accompagne au nom de
la tradition républicaine
on peut pointer des plats industriels il
y a pas que ça qu'on doit pointer on
peut pointer d'autres causes qui sont
assez inédites par exemple la pollution
la pollution est l'un des pourvoyeurs de
l'obésité actuellement en France on
stocke les polluants dans le tissu
adipeux donc certains d'entre nous
devenons plus gras pour nous adapter à
la société qui est en train de devenir
obésogène c'est bien qu'il se déplace
pour venir voir c'est bien mais c'est
pas venir voir seulement il faut qu'il
applique les choses envers les faveur de
travail tout a augmenté tout est cher et
le salaire n'augmente pas le président
écoute les travailleurs de Rungis mais
cause toujours tu m'intéresses et ça
règle le président le sait n'écoute que
lui-même c'est à travers les gens juste
174 ans c'est pas être humain il faut
qu'il soit un peu
humain
je vous la voyez cette image c'est
l'image d'une députée avec ce
commentaire tenu divers d'une députée on
redoute l'été les hélits occidentales ne
cachent pas leur objectif d'infliger
comme elle le disent une défaite
stratégique à la Russie qu'est-ce que
cela signifie cela signifie en finir
avec nous une bonne fois pour toute
Jean-Luc Mélenchon car rien d'autre à
faire président de la France insoumise
les attaques sexistes contre la tenue de
la députée
Ersilia soudais sont une honte ni plus
ni moins dit-il elle mériterait la mise
en retrait de celui qui les tient au nom
d'une association respectée regardez ce
qu'ils font avec leur propre peuple la
destruction des familles des identités
culturelles et nationales la perversion
et la maltraitance des enfants jusqu'à
la pédophilie sont déclarés comme étant
la norme
par par cette campagne l'utilisation
politique et politicienne de cela moi
j'ai voulu attaquer personne surtout pas
cette femme je ne sais d'ailleurs pas
qui c'était j'ai même la tenue j'ai rien
à dire je dis simplement que cette tenue
est inappropriée dans ce lieu le
président Poutine a choisi cette guerre
chaque jour de guerre en plus et son
choix
l'enquête commence par un signalement
celui d'un autre homme une connaissance
de Pierre Palmade lui affirme avoir
passé plusieurs soirées avec l'acteur
qui lui aurait montré une vidéo mettant
en scène des mineurs et à Venise aussi
le manque de plus à des conséquences
très visibles vous allez voir ces images
de canaux quasiment à sec et des
gondoles échoués en cause une marée
basse fréquente à cette période de
l'année mais d'une durée exceptionnelle
du fait de l'absence de précipitation